I must be so fun to be back slinging
derbs with the old gang no no it sucks
okay who's that
[Applause]
who's happening let's go
this is no joke this is catering so what
would you say is the biggest difference
between how it feels to to put on the
pink bow tie then versus now both for
Henry as a character but also for you as
an actor who's accomplished quite a bit
since 2010
you know back when we first started
making the show in 2008 and we finished
in 2010 but when we first started making
the show I think all of us the entire
cast really connected directly with
these characters and their predicament
and
the fact that you know success was just
sort of beyond their just out of their
grasp and we all you know had our faces
up against a glass a bit of Show
Business and
so we were we really deeply felt this
show and also we didn't think anyone
would ever see it really there was no
streaming back then Stars it wasn't
really making shows it was
so we just didn't we didn't think it
would really be a thing it never
occurred to us so we were really just
making it for ourselves and for each
other and we're having such a good time
that we didn't care if no one ever saw
it we just wanted to keep doing it uh
because I think part of it was it felt
good to be able to really kind of and it
was maybe therapeutic to express this
sort of
um the uh the the the feelings that you
have when you're in trying to break into
Show Business and it's just rejection
after rejection
um and now it's 13 years later and
um you know the great thing is is that
it was
difficult to find six weeks where all
these now very busy people could uh
could get together to make another
season and luckily we could uh we could
find that time but
um
but I think all of the characters
including Henry my character are very
much the same people but it's just been
um it's been a while and they're older
and maybe a little more comfortable in
their skin a little more settled a lot
of uh similarities and continued story
arcs but one of my favorite new elements
of the season is the Evie Henry Dynamic
and I'm a big fan of Jennifer Garner too
so it was making me wonder what were
your expectations for working with her
going in and how did maybe she meet
those expectations if not surprise you
yeah I mean I've been a fan of
Jennifer's for so long I've always
wanted to work with her uh so it was a
real thrill I mean when we were talking
about the role of Evie we were talking
about Jennifer Garner as like a type uh
you know like someone like Jennifer
Garner never thinking we would actually
get Jennifer Garner to be on party down
so it was kind of absurd when she said
yes and and then we we had her come to
the set and and we were all sort of on
our best behavior
but then she walked on and she was just
immediately hilarious and right at home
uh and just killed it she was so good
and so much fun
um and is obviously a a great actor but
also hilarious which she's been
hilarious before if you watched 13 Going
on 30 you know you know that she's super
funny
um and it was uh it was really really
fun to see her just score time and again
on the show and assure you I've watched
13 Going on 30 too many times over the
years sure to wrap here just for fun and
because I'm curious but I also think I
might know the answer to this do you
think that Henry ever even for a second
would consider joining the severance
program or would he genuinely want to
remember all the good times he's had at
party down oh I think if Henry could
sever uh his his time uh catering he
would do it in a second no
oh absolutely but then immediately
regret it and realized that he's missing
all of the best people in his life okay
that's fair as long as you turn it back
around then I'm willing to buy that
answer yeah but he would give it a shot
this is an important event no personal
business on company ah group photo okay
get the whole gang weren't we the gang
and you were more management now it's a
party down reunion what everyone's dying
for so there's a lot of reboots and
Revival series out there right now can
you each name something unique to party
down that makes it stand out from the
pack that we have well we didn't we
didn't uh in reinvent the wheel for sure
we knew what made it good and thank God
John embaum is writing every episode
because he's the guy who wrote him uh 10
years ago or however many years ago it
was
um uh and so it's just a very faithful
adherence to what made that so wonderful
which is the characters but 10 years
later which makes it even funnier on
some levels yeah I think it's more I
think you're you're gonna get a strong
story funny story with the same
characters and it's it's another season
of of if you like these first two
seasons you're gonna like this one and
more of the same that I love but also
just enough Evolution that I really
appreciate also kind of kind of does
feel like you're a little bit of a rely
of a Revival good luck charm between you
know this Veronica Mars Wet Hot American
Summer if you could reboot or revive one
other thing you've been a part of in the
past what would you choose and why uh it
would either be
um uh Burning Love uh or uh maybe
another guy young
um uh Eastbound and Down experience I'm
I'm fine with those answers but I
believe the only right answer to that
question is Bad Milo
yeah another butt monster movie
seriously we need more butt monster
movies in the world now you know I was
hoping that there would be another
another uh uh a sequel to that movie
because
um I I really enjoyed doing that movie
that movie what it would be uh feel like
and look like having a monster come out
my butt and also going up back into my
butt anyway I would say that's that's a
real achievement right there well watch
Bad Milo you'll really get a sense of it
get a sense of it I could not recommend
that movie enough uh in a terrible pivot
here a more serious question for you
Jane I know that you said uh constant
Constance is constant and she's pretty
much the exact same person so for you
playing her what is the key to
maintaining that consistency and that
quality but also embracing the new
layers that the show adds to her in
season three right well I always have to
remember that Constance is innocence
she she's she's
guileless and
um and I that can make a person appear
stupid but really truly she just kind of
believes everything that comes out of
people's mouths and um she believes her
own uh backstory that's created for
herself that never really happened she
was never really a
um you know she talks about the acting
in the 80s and it never really happened
she was probably an extra if anything uh
in the background and um she wakes up
living the dream can you each a recall a
time in your careers when you know maybe
all seemed lost but someone swooped in
at just the right moment gave you what
you needed and you were able to forge
forward I was uh my real answer to that
is
um you know uh I was
in town in Hollywood and a lot of the
parts I was playing was sort of like
nice guy boyfriend like leading man in a
comedy kind of thing or whatever I could
those were the type of parts I was
getting and then uh Rob Thomas and Dan
Etheridge uh offered me uh Vinnie Van
low on
um on Veronica Mars and I got to come in
with a character
um and play a different version and and
from that moment on uh and then and and
while I was shooting that they uh Dan
Etheridge gave me party down to read the
script and I was like if you ever have
auditions for Ron please let me know
because I have a take on that guy but
from Veronica Mars on
uh and it was right during wet Hot
American Summer too I got to play more
uh charactery parts that
um feed me and and and get me more
excited and so that that that that them
giving me that opportunity was a big
thing a big deal for me
how about for you Jane uh well my
parents jumping in with six hundred
dollars for my rent here and there which
happened a lot when I first got to LA
but I would get I would say when uh
Christopher Guest gave me uh cast me in
a commercial uh for Kellogg's Frosted
Flakes in 1999 and that great commercial
oh thank you so much
and um it was it opened up a door I mean
literally he you know he he's one of
those people that he says he can tell
within 15 seconds if you could do what
he needs you to do as an actor and um I
guess I passed those 15 seconds and then
um he cast me and everything after that
so that was a that was a huge moment
that he had the faith in in me you know
he has faith that everybody that he
casts he wouldn't cast him if he didn't
have that faith and when someone has
faith in you
man it can make you a little it's a
little daunting but it can also just
feed you and just yeah I can do this if
he thinks I can do this I can do this so
that really was a big confidence booster
for me well always have faith in you and
in particular I have faith that you'll
watch Ken's butt monster movie oh I
should do that
no it's actually him cool yeah see you
in 12 years I know there was a lot of
enthusiasm going into season three of
the show so for each of you what was the
thing you were most looking forward to
tapping back into but then while you
were making the show what is something
creatively fulfilling you discovered
that you never could have imagined
my love of uh the new people that we got
blessed with this time around
um Zoe Tyrell Jennifer it's it's that's
been the most fun is to to invite new
people into this weird little world I
honestly the thing that's been most fun
is that I was looking forward to the
most just hanging out like this was the
only job that you know 13 years ago that
um was so fun on the days where you
weren't working you'd still come into
set
um so it's so great to be back at summer
camp and and having a blast and
especially with the way that everyone's
careers are shaping it was really hard
to find the time in Ryan's schedule to
make this work but we did thank God and
uh you know it's it's tough you know
it's it's tough now with with everyone's
success as well but
thank God you know I think Adam has been
really pioneering this in a big way and
obviously everybody else we've all
wanted it to happen but
um you know the push finally occurred
and here we are and just to be clear
just to be clear Martin was the only one
that showed up when he wasn't working so
I really liked it there even though
people kept saying go home I I loved it
and uh it was I thought it was you know
just banter but it sounded like maybe
I'm a big believer that kind of Cast
Connection does truly radiate off screen
so it does mean a lot that you guys
really have it
um Ryan what about for you maybe
something you found uh that was more
creatively fulfilling in your role than
you ever realized was there in seasons
one and two
more creatively fulfilling I I don't
know I to me I think honestly just just
getting to um be able to say the words
that John edenbaum has put down on these
amazing scripts for me is the most
fulfilling thing ever it's like party
Down's like one of the coolest projects
the best projects I've ever done so to
get to do it again 13 years later
and uh and still not have aged a day
thank you so much that's not true I've
aged a little bad
um but to be able to be with this cast
again who we we all love each other so
much like Martin was saying and it's
just true we just have a blast on and
offset and I think it's kind of like uh
people say that but we really do
in all seriousness none of you have aged
a day like it's kind of weird it's kind
of weird whatever
when you're on set on your off days like
it's working that's 50 honest
no specific question for you because
Romans always felt just like completely
impossible to please when it comes to
hard sci-fi stories so of all the hard
sci-fi films that have come out between
2010 and now which release do you think
he would actually appreciate come on
Martin what do you got oh my God this is
such a specific question I have no idea
how to answer I don't follow sci-fi
anywhere near well enough to know what
to say right now I will spoon feed you
an answer and would probably say Dune uh
I actually did like Dune
um you make fun of it though in that
show yeah yeah yeah for sure but I I'm
curious to see how the the next two
movies turn out but it was
it was a decent intro to the book
makes fun of Star Wars in the show
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um of course I'm Amy how can you not
even the originals you know God God Rest
they're a lot of fun no yeah they're
very they're a lot of fun they're campy
uh you love them all every single one I
do I do love it I mean every single one
honestly for a variety of reasons we're
talking jar jar yeah there's a charm to
jar jar that I think was very accessible
to Young moviegoers that maybe brought
them into the franchise when they were
first exploring it via that character so
it is it is a great Jar Jar Binks do it
let's hear it let's hear it
that was in private and I will never do
that I told you when I did it I filmed
it I'll send it to you no yeah but we're
gonna make this happen right after
because they're kicking me out now but I
expect to get that video soon thank you
guys for your time and congratulations
on season three
this is a big opportunity I'm a tight
Professional Service
this is not
it's night vision my my 40s
[Music]
our production notes are basically
filled with quotes about how much the
original cast genuinely loved each other
so what was your first taste of that
when you started making season three and
how would you say that Vibe influenced
your own work or experience for the
better the first day of shooting was the
first day of shooting like the first day
everyone came back to to shoot first
time
um and it was really striking just how
much of a family environment it was and
how comfortable everyone was with each
other and and it was a very warm you
know sort of uh
like a relaxed environment you're still
working but like everyone was like just
like comfortable and willing to play and
have fun with each other so it was easy
to be like
right I can you know
I can find my I can take my time and
find my place in this and you know no
one was it was in hostile it was very
comfortable I bet for you uh Zoe
anything in particular that stood out
when you first got on set
I mean same I joined a week later
um and just was so nervous to join this
iconic cast and
um it took me a week or two to just like
calm down uh but it it was not their
fault at all they were they welcomed us
with open arms but um you know I just
think that there this is such a highly
anticipated
um comeback and and uh I didn't want to
mess it up so I I was very nervous but
we quickly felt like a part of the
family and I love those weirdos
nerves come from caring and feeling
passionate about something so I embrace
them
um to highlight Saxon and Lucy a little
bit here so I love how the show has
grounded qualities to it but there's
also some really heightened comedy in
the mix so can you each name something
specific about them or something that
they do that might have stopped and made
you go like how is this gonna work but
it wound up playing really well in the
final show
I I definitely the
amount of reverence that Saxon gives
every bit of content that he makes was
something that I thought was hilarious
and I was also like okay this is
I got a really good specific about how I
play this you know
irrespective yeah I think yeah I love
the way Saxon would celebrate everybody
yes my free content he got on the camera
um I think for Lucy
yeah I mean the fact that she is not
concerned with what the food tastes like
but but what feelings are um inspired is
so funny to me
um I think she's a real nut and
um has such a clear passion you know
clear objective she and dream
um and so I admire her passion
um and her fight uh
yeah I think she yeah I was just so
excited to audition for her because she
she's one of a kind all right I'll wrap
with this one here so given Saxon is an
influencer and Lucy's a food artist can
you both tell me what is the most recent
food photo you've taken with your phone
good question that is a good question oh
man
oh last night
I checked we ordered three desserts two
and my friend and I ordered three
desserts and I was like pow got a
document but also like I never post them
because
Why YouTube people do that but also
I do love food so maybe I should start
posting him but the chocolate we've got
two different kinds of uh chocolate
dessert and then some really good uh ice
cream at Chateau Marmont I have more
respect for you than ever right now
solidness thank you what was your last
favorite item um I uh I don't know if
this is the last food item I took a
picture of but I remember I went to uh a
friend of mine had a destination wedding
in Italy it's my first time out of like
out of the country and that was the
first time I felt the need to take
pictures of what I was eating so I was
like I people need to know that like
like it's every you know every
subsequent meal I had was like the the
next meal was the best meal I'd ever had
so I was like I need people to
understand yes what's party down with an
m
so it is a feat to make any show it's a
special something to bring a show back
so many years later like this and it was
making me curious what would you maybe
call the low point in that effort a time
when you said to yourself like maybe it
won't happen after all but then
ultimately you overcame that challenge
and you saw it through to fruition oh
boy
um I mean I don't know if we ever had a
low point so much as there was just the
plateau at which we were like well we
have no idea how we might be able to do
this but
we'll just keep taking whatever
opportunity pops up
um because we definitely you know we
spent a lot of
you know on and off for years and years
trying to sort of figure out ways to
kind of you know could we could we pitch
this version could we you know oh
there's new Executives that we could go
meet and be like hey remember this show
um so you know I I guess Hope Springs
Eternal was kind of our you know
long-standing motto and you know we
really lucked out in that uh we just had
read an interview with the new head of
stars
um who had made reference to missing
party down like as a show that had been
on the network that you know they no
longer had on and so Rob Thomas just
called him up the next day and was just
like guess what we're still here
um and so you know I guess that's runs a
little counter to the party down ethos
of something like good luck happening
but that's kind of what happened to us
well I'm glad it went that way for you
so you probably did just break down how
you got this back off the ground but you
know from our limited perspective from
where we stand it can kind of feel like
almost like a mythological magic trick
to bring a show back from cancellation
so based on your experience with this
and Veronica Mars what maybe tip or
piece of advice would you give to
another showrunner out there who saw
their their baby get canceled and they
want a chance of bringing it back to
life
um you know I think what worked for us
is the fact that you know we never lost
touch with the cast and we always you
know had just a very warm spot in our
heart for it
um so that we you know we all kind of
knew if we got the opportunity that we
would you know jump at it and we also
feel like just the
the nature of the show The Format of the
show the themes of the show are kind of
Evergreen and eternal or whatever in our
minds and therefore there's no reason
not to do it you can't say like oh you
know people don't you know ride trains
anymore you know it's not a train show
it's a you know its themes are more
relevant now I think than they ever were
and so you know we feel like it's
something that you know until we're like
you know on the moon or whatever is
going to remain relevant and so we're
always confident that we can do it and
so we're just looking for the chance I
was really impressed by how you evolved
a lot of those themes with this new
season and I was also curious because I
know with seasons one and two of the
show the focus was on writing Episode by
episode but in season three you put more
of a focus on having a fluid Arc What
specifically inspired that change does
it have anything to do with how viewing
habits have evolved since season two uh
it's all of the above I mean definitely
you know viewing having bits of change
what people look for has changed but
also you know we had six episodes rather
than ten
um and we also
um you know didn't feel that we could
just pick up with the more episodic
nature of it we had to sort of explain a
little bit more where everybody was
where they're wanting to go and so it
felt like you know this go around we
kind of had to we felt like we owed it
to you know just the show itself to be a
little more you know serialized to tell
a continuous kind of little contained
Arc of a story but you know that
obviously would stay true to kind of you
know the the spirit of the show and
everything
um but yeah because of the fact that we
you know wanted to
treat the passage of time realistically
and meet these people where you know we
think they would have been as opposed to
just you know jumping right back where
we left off 12 years ago
um you know we wanted to see how people
were dealing with you know their lack of
success or successes that they had or
where you know whatever's happening in
their lives and do it as people who are
12 years older than you know the people
they you know little whatever baby
Martin Starr or whatever